Hello everybody, welcome to another Zoom call.
We won't get into your questions.
We didn't have everybody questions submitted, only two this week.
So if you have questions, you may want to get them in,
where this is going to be a very short Zoom call.
Okay.
Reminder you can schedule follow-up calls
on the member site or on the regular website as well.
This is not really a health question, but how do you know if the question I submit was actually submitted.
It stays on the screen.
Yeah, I know that is a feature in HubSpot that we have no control over.
Well, you didn't figure it out.
Okay.
But I think so.
If you know what the difference is, I'm never on that side where I'm actually submitting questions.
So I don't know how to answer that question.
I do know that other people have had struggles with it,
because sometimes they'll submit like three times,
and it'll be the exact same question over and over.
So there I have a trouble finding out whether it's active submitting or not.
So I do know that that can be an issue.
So you're not alone.
Okay, question.
I can take my Dutch test samples beginning next Thursday.
Do I stop taking my supplements three days prior?
I called precision diagnostics and they said that I can do that,
especially with the high dose melatonin,
because that is a hormone can affect the other hormones.
However, they said that if you want results without the effects of dim an estrogen,
then you'll really have to stop that two to four weeks prior.
You think it's a good idea to take the dim to see how that is working.
My previous Dutch test was in 2021,
and there were no huge red flags.
So I don't know if we care about comparison.
I'm not sure I want to stop taking my dim.
They say to note the melatonin if I continue to take it.
So there's different two different ways when you're looking at a functional lab like this.
It's similar to testing for food sensitivities.
If you really want to push the boundary of food sensitivity,
so you're concerned about gluten,
then you would purposely eat more gluten before running the lab,
which is not highly advisable with gluten.
But there are some people that will stay if they've been staying off gluten,
then their lab can actually show no antibodies to gluten.
So I tend to fall on the side of live how you normally live,
and run the test how you normally live.
Same thing with hormones, hormones fluctuate day to day.
So if your if you want to have,
so if your purpose was,
in this case,
if you want to eat gluten,
then you're going to eat gluten.
So I tend to fall on the side of
live how you normally live,
because in this case, with the Dutch test,
if their purpose was,
I don't want to be taking my dim forever.
So I want to know how my hormones would do without taking the dim,
then I would say,
then if that's what you want to find out,
then I would say go off of it for four weeks,
and see how your hormones,
what the balance is after being off of it for four weeks.
In the world, you would do that,
and then okay, they're normal.
I'm going to stay off and dim.
I would redo the test maybe in three months to see if it stays that way,
because your body could change.
But if that's not your concern,
my concern is to get off and dim.
I want to just keep my,
I don't want this cancer to come back.
I want to keep my estrogen levels down.
Then I would keep take that I would purposely,
I would purposely keep taking the dim,
because I want to know what my hormones,
what I'm doing, what I will normally do,
and what I will continue to do, which is take the dim.
Now I don't think there's anything wrong with going off the melatonin
for several days beforehand,
because that may be something you're not going to stay on for the rest of your life.
But I would fall into the camp that I would keep taking the dim,
note it on there,
and I would probably stop taking the melatonin
and note it on there that you were taking it.
Okay, that was all the questions that had submitted.
So if you have questions, you'll need to chat them in.
Another practitioner had me take something called tonka,
which is supposed to support the liver.
So tonka helps support detoxification, yes.
The first time I took it,
I started having muscle spasms that lasted a long time.
You sell the same product at your store.
What do you think happened?
I sent in a cheek swab to test for this as well.
So what could possibly have let me pull up tonka here
to make sure I have all the,
I don't have all the ingredients of tonka memorized.
But so a couple of things with tonka.
So tonka has the tonka,
which is toro,
orso, deoxocolic acid,
which is, which is helps with liver detoxification,
helps with cellular detoxification.
Could a person have a reaction to that?
Because it's kind of, honestly,
it's kind of on symptoms of having muscle spasms.
So could a person have a reaction to that?
Other things in here is etacetal cystine,
which helps produce glutathione,
melatonin, which is, you know,
obviously melatonin is good for producing sleep.
And it can be in high enough concentration,
it can be an oxidizing agent per cancer.
And it has bioactive carbon in it,
which is another binder.
So tonka is used for liver,
use for detoxification.
Enocinyl cystine is the part mainly for liver,
and for Cell function for,
it supports phase 2 detoxification pathways with glutinyle.
I would say it's a reaction,
I would say it's a reaction to the product.
Could be the tonka, a reaction to that.
I don't think it be,
the muscle spasms would be tied to anything,
but the tonka.
So you could have a sensitivity to something.
So I would say it's probably that.
Yeah, I mean, it's possible that it really was nothing
to do with the products.
It was maybe just something else that was going on.
You had a reaction to something different.
I don't know, but I typically don't recommend
tonnecophore or cancer patients.
I don't always even test for it.
Because I do test for other glutathione type products
with everybody and most people don't test well at a cancer.
And it has to do with that oxidative stress component
that we talked about multiple times.
So, but I will definitely test that for you again.
The only other thing about the Dutch test people told me
was the corsetet, which is in white greens.
So I just said that I will take that and then
it will tone it.
Okay, that sounds good.
I don't think there's enough corsetet in your greens
to make a difference.
It's not that high of a dose, but I think that's fine.
I think we want to get as clean a test as possible.
I think that's just fine.
It's not something you need on a daily basis in a home.
A PET scan done yesterday showed increased tumor activity
in my liver, which is very concerning for detox.
I am doing coffee animals three times.
A week, foot baths, four times a week,
sauna, intermittently, epsom salt baths,
one to two times a per week.
Should I change or increase these?
I would, what I would increase is the coffee animals.
I would be doing that daily.
If you were asking back Gerson this question 50 years ago,
well, not to be longer than that.
But when he was alive, he would say you need
to do coffee animals three times a day.
So the best way to help flush out the liver,
to help with cancer that's metastasized to the liver
is supporting it with coffee animals.
So I would say increased coffee animals.
Foot baths, I would leave it alone.
Saunas, I would increase the saunas
if you have the time to do that.
The saunas help take a ton of stress off the liver
because you're helping detox through the skin.
Remember, your liver is assaulted with a amount of toxins
that have to process through that little organ
to get out of your body.
If you can take any pressure off of them,
the better off you're gonna be.
Epsom salt baths are not really detoxifying,
maybe a little bit, helps maybe a little bit
through your skin, they're relaxing
and relaxing can help stimulate parasympathetic.
So in that sense, from a neurological stimulation,
they can help with detoxification.
So I would do that as comfortable as frequently as you want.
You could do those every day if you wanted to.
But I would definitely increase the coffee animals.
Try to get to where you're doing that daily.
The oncologist told me to stop all supplements
and go on to moxifin only for three weeks.
None of the supplements interfere, do they?
I've done as she requested.
Okay, so this is the foolish thing about some oncologists.
They don't know, some of them are very informed
because they've done a little extra study.
They certainly didn't learn anything in school.
And ones that I haven't done any extra study,
just do this completely scorched earth philosophy.
Don't take any supplements.
First of all, to moxifin does not,
is it a rheumatized inhibitor to moxifin
isn't doing an oxidative stress function in the body?
So I wouldn't say that you have to go off.
All supplements.
I wouldn't say really going on
to moxifin makes you want to go off any supplements.
So if a person is doing a keyboard therapy protocol,
that's an oxidative stress protocol,
then for sure that's where I can understand it.
It ignorant, I mean that in a nice way,
oncologist would take you off of all supplements
because they just don't want to look up
whether a supplement is antioxidant or not.
They don't want any antioxidants.
But I would say that to say that a person
should go off of all supplements
when you're doing a more hormonal-based therapy
when you're reducing hormones.
It does make any sense whatsoever.
Less of course, versus hormones,
but that doesn't make any sense whatsoever.
I'm scheduled for a lupron shot
to shut down the ovaries June 3rd.
No noticeable side effects for the toxin
during the first week so far.
That's fantastic.
I got my blood lab stun
and the only thing that seemed off to me was the ALT,
which was a nine in a couple,
which was a nine a couple months ago in a 23 last week.
Other enzymes were my normal, very low.
Is anything to be concerned about?
Well, you know, I don't know.
So when you're looking at your lab results,
what you see in the ranges is the lab ranges.
So there's a difference between lab ranges and functional ranges.
So something could be within normal lab ranges,
but could be at the high or low end of that lab range
would usually make it out of range as far as a functional range.
But then you have to look at patterns.
So when you look at a lab,
you look at a functional range
then you look at patterns of what's off.
And then you look at a previous lab.
So you look at trends.
So that's how you need to really read a lab report.
ALT of 23, I believe still is within the functional range.
If everything else was within the lab range,
again, it could be outside in the functional range.
So we'd have to look at the big picture there.
What is the reason for the pain in the left foot sole?
So are you saying you have pain in your left foot?
Well, there could be a hundred reasons for that.
Did you injure the site?
Did you, you can, so the left foot sole,
to be aware it is in your foot,
is it on the lateral side of your foot?
Most common cause of that
is diphthmetatarsal stress fracture,
which is extremely common
if you're working on country
or walking on concrete all the time.
If it's on the
medial side, you could have, you know, arch issues to,
I mean, all sorts of musculoskeletal things
could be going on.
Does cancer metastasize to your feet?
Very, very, very rarely.
I don't think that's a concern,
even enter into the mind of an oncologist.
So there's just all sorts of musculoskeletal things
that could be going on,
a good thing to go to a chiropractor or somebody
who could maybe take some x-rays
and see what's going on, do an examination.
Could you discuss what you learned about the L salivarius
protocol?
My chiropractor thinks it can cure cancer
as he had a spot on his cheek
and he took four capsidate
and it ate a hole in his cheek.
He wants me to take nine capsidate,
but since I'm seen flesh being eaten away,
I decided to stop it.
I mentioned it last week, yes.
So it's really interesting.
Once I looked it up, I realized,
oh yeah, I did look at this before.
It is a lactobacillus protocol,
probiotic, microbiota,
and it shows really a lot of promise in cancer.
So I would be careful to say anything can cure cancer,
but the truth is lots of things can
and would it cure everybody's cancer?
Of course, nothing will cure everybody's cancer,
but I don't think there's any harm in taking it.
So there's multiple peer-reviewed studies on it,
quite interesting.
I'm actually gonna write a blog about it,
but you know, he'd wait for my blog.
I don't think there's anything wrong with taking it.
And the product that you sent me
only showed what was it?
Two billion units of the salivarius
in that probiotic.
That's not even a high dose.
So I don't see anything wrong with you taking it.
You can certainly, if he muscle tested you on that nine caps,
there's nothing wrong with you titrating up to that.
And if it is causing like it eating away,
it's not gonna eat away healthy tissue.
So it would only eat unhealthy tissue.
So I don't think there's anything wrong with taking it.
I'll tell you, I just talked to somebody today
about another protocol that I've used
on people whether it's cancer related or not.
Years and years ago,
cautious was back in the 90s.
I had a patient that came to see me.
This is what actually was practicing down in Texas
when we were doing missionary work.
And he had a hole in the bottom of his foot
and you could see his bone.
And this was going on for about a year.
And he could not get better.
He'd been to every wound specialist
taking antibiotic creams and ointments, all that stuff.
And I was practicing with a friend of mine
who also did kinesiology.
He was older than me.
And he actually gave me the idea of testing for probiotic.
So we tested him for probiotic and can't remember
what probiotic it was irrelevant.
And all he did is open up the capsule of probiotic
and sprinkle it in the wound.
And it healed up completely in two weeks.
So it was amazing.
Since that time, it was a long time ago,
I've done that little protocol on wounds
that wouldn't heal sprinkly a probiotic in it.
And it was not a specific probiotic.
So this is a specific probiotic
that this person is talking about here
that in this question that has been shown
to help kill cancer cells.
And it's been proven that it does do that.
But there's hundreds and hundreds of published reports,
published studies on curcumin and burburied
and all the supplements that we talk about on a daily basis
in our office.
There's hundreds of published reports
proving that they have curative properties for cancer.
So it's not uncommon that a probiotic
of this magnitude would do the same thing.
So I don't think there's anything wrong with taking it.
And I don't think there's anything wrong with
if you have an open wound, sprinkle something
directly into the open wound.
And I don't think there's anything wrong
with it eating away and creating an open wound.
That's exactly what happens when we treat,
when we treat melanova with black sap,
it literally creates a crater.
I mean, it literally looks like a wound crater on your skin
because it literally eats away the cancer
and the cancer comes out.
And then you have to throw away the little piece of cancer
that came out of the skin.
And we've seen miraculous things with that too,
but it doesn't necessarily look good when it leaves this crater,
but it does heal up and it will heal with a scar.
But better not to have the cancer, so.
I think it's a great thing.
I think you should go back on it.
I wouldn't be afraid of it.
Next question, what about castor oil packs?
How often for detoxifications?
Yeah, so castor oil packs over the liver.
You can do that daily.
You could just do a hot pack over the liver.
Castor oil packs, the only negative is just that they're messy.
And all these things that we're talking about just take time.
So it just depends on how much time you have
to do all these things.
But castor oil packs another good thing to do
over the liver that would be helpful too.
Is there any problem with doing foot bath
since I have a pacemaker and do the foot baths
affect your electrolytes?
My potassium tends to be low.
No, if you're doing a foot bath every day,
could it cause you to lose more electrolytes?
Maybe a little,
would you have to be careful with,
if you have low potassium and you have low electrolytes
and you have trouble keeping minerals in your body
would be so much more than foot baths.
I don't think you're really gonna lose a lot.
If you're using an ionic foot bath,
which is a little bit different than the true right foot bath,
you'd have a greater chance of losing minerals.
You say that, but still I don't think you're losing
a lot of minerals with a foot bath.
If you don't be, I don't recommend doing foot baths
every day anyhow, so, but I think you'd be safe
doing foot baths.
I'm always dealing with constipation,
trying to get a number of magnesium capsules
and aloe capsules, correct.
I've had a bit of success with taking
straight coconut oil actually,
but I have noticed I seem to have lost
a natural urge to have a bowel movement.
Can my daily animals be responsible
for the lack of parasitosis?
Yes, that's what it's called, making my balls lazy.
So yes, if you're doing daily coffee
animals for a long time, it can affect your urge to go
and you can feel like you can become dependent
upon the coffee animal.
So, if your cancers in remission,
you don't need to continue to do coffee animals.
Typically, your balls get back in order
and within about a week.
If you've always had to deal with constipation,
you do want to kind of look at other possible issues
going on and you've got two.
Do you have, again, I don't have your full history
in front of me, did you ever have a surgery
that could have caused adhesions?
Do you have, are you going to a carpenter
that does kinesiology?
They may want to check your ileoceco valve.
That's the valve between your large and small intestine.
That could be blocked.
I think I talked a little bit about the ileoceco valve
in the video on how to deal with a heightal herdea.
That's on our blogs.
If you go to our blog and you search heightal herdea,
I give a video demonstration of how to pull down
the heightal herdea.
I think in that video, I made it a number of years ago,
but I think I talked about a heightal herdea
ileoceco valve issue in there as well.
So check that that might be part of your issue.
That would be a simple fix.
And then just the health of the gut as far as
damage cut wall and such can be issues with constipation.
And then a big thing with constipation and big thing
with the health of the gut are people are not testing
for food sensitivities and dealing with that.
And they're like part of it is that,
and you might be in this category that the test is expensive.
It's 500 and some bucks and you don't want to do it.
Other people are in the category that I can eat anything.
My stomach's like a rock and I don't have any sensitivities
and I don't feel bad after I eat things.
And they're failing to understand that you're not looking
for pain or discomfort after eating as your side
of inflammation of the gut.
So remember, the only pain fibers you have
in the intestinal tract are distention fibers.
I could literally go in there and cut up your intestinal tract.
You won't feel a thing.
Of course you plead to death.
That wouldn't be a good experiment.
But you don't have pain fibers except fibers
that cause that are distention fibers.
Meaning you have gas build up and all my tummy really hurts.
So you don't get gas build up and your tummy really hurting
always when you have an inflammatory reaction in the gut.
So testing for things and I've had people run the test
and have nothing come up.
Well that's just great.
But more commonly a person run the test
and they swear I know nothing's gonna come up
and a whole bunch of things come up.
Perseveral things come up and they go, oh my goodness.
I guess I eat that a lot.
And then you can look up and see what's cross-reactive
to that thing and you go, wow, I need to stay off of that.
I've had people be gluten free, dairy free diet,
I think they're doing everything right.
They do a CyRex 10 and they come up with some food product
that is in gluten free foods, like tapioca starch.
And they are show up in the red for tapioca starch
and they've eaten tapioca starch every time
they eat gluten free bread.
And that's just as bad as eating gluten for that person.
So, but they never have any symptoms.
But so testing for that can be why is there to do?
Can I go back on the supplements
and not tell the oncologist and my body will be okay
or benefited?
Well, I can't tell you not to tell your oncologist thing.
So, you know, but I will tell you
that with mass majority of people that do natural things,
don't explain those natural things
to their regular medical doctor or oncologist
or because they, you know, you might as well talk to them all.
And I mean, you just gotta understand,
everybody's gotta stay in their lane.
I try to give them as much grace as possible.
They just, they have enough things to worry about.
They're seeing, you know, 50 patients a day
and they don't have time to study natural things.
Okay, that's an excuse.
They're lazy.
They should be knowing how to take care of their patients.
But it is what it is.
So you can tell you what to do there
but I don't think they're being harmed.
Now, if you were doing a chemotherapy,
it's an oxidizing agent that I would have to look back
at your supplements and make sure you're not taking any
into the oxidants.
I am hypothyroid.
Our proctor muscle test to be on standard process prolybene,
iodine, 30 milligrams of calcium,
600 micrograms of iodine.
He wants me to take nine a day.
It scared me that you said no on iodine.
Then last week, you said that iodine can flip
hypothyroid to Hashimoto's.
My MD said something about iodine stopping estrogen.
So she wasn't so concerned about iodine
but I stopped taking it.
Yeah, so if you want to learn more about that,
I have information on the autoimmune course
which you have access to in the autoimmune course.
I think it's module five that's all about Hashimoto's.
There's multiple studies about people with primary,
so there's different Hashimoto's in somebody
with primary hypothyroidism.
So primary hypothyroidism is diagnosed by a person
having low T3, low T4 elevated TSH
or some combination thereof and negative TPO antibodies
and negative viral globulin antibodies.
Now, if you're listening to me and you go,
I don't even know what those are.
I don't think anybody's ever tested me for those.
Then you don't know if you have primary hypothyroidism
or if you have Hashimoto's.
Because the difference is Hashimoto's patient
is gonna have a combination of low T3,
low T4 elevated TSH and they will have
either a thyroid globulin antibodies elevated
and or TPO antibodies elevated.
That is the definition of if Hashimoto's.
If the person has elevated TPO antibodies
and or elevated thyroid globulin antibodies
and elevated T3 elevated T4 and low TSH,
that's what's called Graves' disease.
So both Graves' disease and Hashimoto's
are an autoimmune thyroid condition.
What is producing an excess thyroid,
which can be very dangerous.
What is producing a hypothyroid?
That's Hashimoto's.
By the way, Hashimoto's can actually have episodes
of excess thyroid production, excess T3 spill,
especially if they eat gluten,
which is a molecular mimic to the thyroid.
So if your high, if your primary hypothyroid
or Hashimoto's or Graves,
you should not be eating gluten at all
because gluten, glianin, protein, and gluten
is a molecular mimic to the thyroid.
So even if you don't have a sensitivity,
meaning if you don't have antibodies to gluten,
it's still a molecular mimic to the thyroid.
So it can produce an excess disruption
of the thyroid gland and issues.
Iodine, so iodine was the question.
Oh, thyroid needs iodine in order to make T3 and T4.
Yes, it does, but if you take exogenous iodine,
meaning iodine in a supplement
and you have primary hypothyroid,
you don't have Hashimoto's at all.
You don't have antibodies to TPO antibodies.
You don't have thyroid gland antibodies.
There's been study after study that show
you have almost a hundred percent chance
of producing thyroid gland or TPO antibodies
if you take iodine for any length of time.
There was one study in Japan that took 354
primary hypothyroid patients.
They did not have TPO or thyroid gland antibodies.
They put them on iodine in every single one of them
with a matter of time had Hashimoto's or Graves' disease,
every single patient.
So iodine was because iodine is a component of T3
back in the 1970s.
Well, that was discovered all natural doctors.
Iodine, we could use iodine, we could sell iodine.
Let's give iodine to our patients.
So they invented these little tests,
these IMA drop tests and all the stuff.
And natural doctors started using iodine like crazy.
Well, I think in many doctors that really understand this
think that it is actually del-right malpractice.
We give everybody iodine.
This is just wrong.
It's very wrong and it's very dangerous.
So that is why we have one of the reasons
why we have an epidemic of Hashimoto's and Graves' disease
in this country is the use of exogenous iodine
from well-mean doctors, but have not got it to
adapt and read the studies.
There's even books on everybody needs iodine.
Okay, did you just gotta be careful
about some of the stuff that it's just not correct?
So I'm not opposed to a person taking iodine
when they've diagnosed with breast cancer
if they don't have any thyroid issues.
But the reason is that iodine is,
the thyroid is just hungry for that mineral.
So it will iodine just literally triggers the thyroid
and it can trigger an immune attack on the thyroid
and that's how you end up producing antibodies
to the thyroid because you're basically triggering
an immune attack to the thyroid.
So that's my story and I go into greater detail
in the autoimmune course on iodine.
It's just not the right thing to do.
And if you never did a full thyroid profile
or let's say you did years ago, you should do that again.
And again, that's full thyroid problem call is taking
is doing T3, T4, 3, T3, T4, or at least one of those sets.
TSH, reverse T3, bioglobulin antibodies and TPO antibodies.
So looking at reverse T3 is important too.
And certainly, if you're not running the antibody test,
which even some thyroid doctors don't do that.
And it's just, I don't get it.
I don't get it.
Okay, my food allergy test is at the lab.
Now Syrex 10, I hope.
So maybe that will have answers to my constipation.
It might, yep.
So that is a picture at least we want to look at.
My new chiropractor said all my trigger points
for my stomach are showing up
and she was pulling down on my upper stomach a lot.
Okay, good.
So maybe she was working.
So your illiosecal valve, your illiosecal valve
is where your appendix is.
So if you think of it's down on the right side
below your liver, that's where your illiosecal valve.
It's actually the point between your obelicus
and your anterior superior iliac spine on the right hand side.
That's that pointy part of your pelvis that sticks out
on the right hand side.
So it's between those two points.
That's what's called McMurdy's point
and that's why your illiosecal valve is.
So if she's pulling down, pushing down
or pushing up on that, whether it's stuck closed
would be the case with constipation.
Also, you know, as she was constipation
is a decreased hydrochloric acid as well.
So I don't know if you're taking HCl
and digestive enzymes with your food
that can help immensely.
So think about that too.
You may want to titrate up on that too.
You may find a difference just in doing that.
So lots of people are taking HCl with their digestive enzymes
but they're just not taking enough
because their stomach has just been so damaged
over the years of that.
It's just, you're just not making it enough.
Okay, good.
All right, last call for questions.
Castorial packs for constipation can help.
If you do absorb some of the castorial
probably help with move your balls
but it's not really like fix for them
or it's not really dealied with the cause
but it can, it might help.
Some people would help.
I would think at least,
why can't they hold the coffee in them?
I can't, I can only get a small amount
and before I need to release it maybe after about three minutes.
You know, that's really common
and don't shame yourself about that.
For me, all the times I did coffee in them
is I could never hold them more than three minutes either.
That's why I developed the easy PZ Lazy Man's way
of coffee in them is it's on the member site
and the detox course and everywhere.
So I would just do it in the shower.
I wouldn't lay on my side.
I wouldn't do any of that.
It just did the whole goal of the coffee in them
is to get that caffeine stimulating
the vagal nerve point in the rectal area.
So don't worry about it.
And the longer you hold it,
I guess the longer stimulation you have on it
but also the greater chance that you have
of absorbing the caffeine,
which has not always been official for everybody
and how well you handle caffeine.
So the lesser time you hold it
then you're gonna absorb less of the caffeine.
It still stimulates the vagal nerve
and that's what the whole purpose of the coffee in them is.
So don't beat yourself up about that.
All right, well thank you guys, everybody be on.
And even though we didn't have a ton of questions submitted
who had a ton of questions,
so that made it super valuable.
And that's what this is all about.
It's just helping everybody get their questions
and serve as best as possible.
Love you all.
I'll be praying for all you
and we'll see you next week.
Bye bye.